[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today today's
question comes from David in Oklahoma he
says my wife and I have started
Financial Peace University way to go
we're on baby step two and we have some
questions currently we have four vehicle
payments and I recently lost my job
we're living off my wife's salary and
unemployment payments we keep hearing
about people selling their vehicles and
buying cheap cars how is this done when
you're upside down
very good we are upside down on all four
vehicles and we want to know how to
downsize we are thinking about
surrendering the motorcycles but that
will end up costing us around 16k after
we sell them any help would be great as
we are determined to get debt free okay
so I actually have a list that they've
given me here so they've got her truck
which is 852 dollars good God
a month by the way they've got her oh no
I'm sorry that was his truck they've got
her SUV for 677 dollars a month and then
they've got two motorcycles once 555 the
other one's 408 now he doesn't tell me
how far upside down they are I'm gonna
assume I think she's 16 on the
motorcycles yeah wrong
well why do you think he's wrong well
because he thinks that that if he said
if that they're going to give him full
price in a repo if you do a voluntary
repo and you take people the keys they
sell your crap on a repo lot oh yeah
you're right he said surrendering don't
do that don't do that if they sell it on
a repo lot they sell it for below
wholesale at a repo price and they sue
you for the difference and it ain't
gonna be 16 dude it's gonna be 25 if you
do that so you don't you don't surrender
you don't do a voluntary repossession
they may take them at some point if you
can't get up right up on the payments
but but don't ever voluntarily because
you lose control of the sale price and
then you've got to work out a settlement
for the difference the deficit balance
so no no on the surrender oh yeah
definitely try to sell them now these
cars uh yeah 852 677 dollars that's
incredibly too high for car payments I
don't know how far upside down they are
again but the idea here is how quickly
can you get some cash stacked up all
right so what I'm doing is if I'm you is
I know you're on baby step two but I
would pause baby step two for a second
so I could stack up all the money you
need to get out of this deal because
essentially this is part of baby step
two so if you've got a lot of your
margin going out to extra payments stop
doing that and start stacking up as much
cash as you can and since you're in baby
step two hopefully that means that
you're uh working overtime I know you
lost your job but right now
is not the time to wait for your dream
job to come along right now get any jobs
you can right
right and take all that money you can
drive because you've got a lot of things
to drive that's true look delivery
services out the Wazoo
now put the kids on the motorcycle to
deliver pizzas so you got three things
you can do when you're upside down one
inch stack cash and cover the difference
so you got a truck that's you know let's
just I can't even get past this I know
852. puke but the um the her SUV okay
677 so she owes 60 000 bucks on the SUV
and when they look it up it's worth 50.
I'm making those numbers up so let's say
that means you're ten thousand dollars
upside down how do you cover that well
one you stack ten thousand dollars and
then you put that with the money with
the buyer that the buyer has at 50 and
you've got 60. now you pay off the SUV
and they send you the title and you give
it to the buyer that's one way second
way is borrow the difference from your
local credit union or for God's sakes
600 852 dollars if you borrow the
difference on a credit card you're still
come out yeah okay you're already eight
bazillion dollars in debt even if your
credit is not just one bazillion dollars
in debt and now it's just not now you're
truckless oh well yeah it's kind of
because Along being clueless so um yeah
even if your credit is shot and you
can't get a good rate from a credit
union just don't dump it on a credit
card it's still debt you're just moving
the debt around all right and then the
third thing is a modification of that if
your truck loan or motorcycle loans are
with your local lender your local credit
union your local bank
go sit down with them in person
and say
hi
I'm unemployed
you're getting ready to get a truck back
you'll want it I don't think you do
turns out this SUV we owe 60 000 on it
with you guys it's worth 50.
you need to help us get out of this so
you don't get stung
this is you talking to your credit union
or bank manager in person not on the
phone and for God's sakes not by email
yeah go sit down and look them in the
eye
in person
and what we want you to do Mr bank
manager is allow us to sign the note for
the difference when it sells so we're
going to put the SUV up for sale for 52
000. it's going to sell for 50 and we're
going to come in here and we're going to
sign an unsecured note for ten thousand
dollars because you already have an
unsecured note for ten thousand dollars
because you have a sixty thousand dollar
loan on a fifty thousand dollar asset
so you are already ten thousand dollars
unsecured all we're doing with this
transaction is admitting it and lowering
our debt by five sixths therefore we
have a higher probability of actually
paying you because we can survive and so
you talk them into converting the upside
down portion into an unsecured note
which by the way it's already where they
are they're already unsecured for that
amount yeah and you can do that if you
go in person and present this logic to
them plus you're you know you're a
bankruptcy looking for a place to happen
right now and in which case they get a
whole bunch of new trucks sitting in
their driveway at the bank and uh
they're going to get nothing yeah
because they sue you for the deficit you
get nothing in bankruptcy on the deficit
zero they do and something tells me I
don't know I could be wrong uh David in
Oklahoma but somebody tells me with
these trucks and vehicles you got more
stuff laying around to get rid of you've
got riding laws collects toys he's got
riding mowers he's got a Peloton he's
got he there's some stuff that can be
sold and liquidated for a bunch of stuff
a bunch of look at everything don't tell
me you have a tractor I'll kill you
don't kill me just don't tell me right
now so they're choosing violence just
sell the tractor no I mean I know this
guy because I was this guy yeah and I'm
just a boy that collects toys yeah and
the problem with the boy that collects
toys is we collect payments with them if
we're broke people do they have a golf
cart too uh uh they might have a golf
cart so man yeah that yeah there's they
for sure have a zero turn that's six
thousand bucks
for sure I was
I wish that a lawnmower costs that much
I didn't know Dave until I saw him
sitting out there and I was like wait a
second you've got to be there's a lot of
lawn mowers that are nicer and more
expensive than my first three cars